would you not agree with that I wouldn't
disagree with that he's also agreeing
with the Quran we're getting there guys
he's going to be become a Muslim
today defend against a rapid spread of
microplasma pneumonia AKA white lung
disease using black resins cogit packed
with immune boosting properties pagit
has been scientifically proven to
promote resp
Health aiding in oxygen absorption while
also making the body infection resistant
strengthen your family's immune system
ahead of the new outbreak this winter
don't forget to use my discount code Ali
dawa for 15% off enjoy all right Salam
alikum guys as you guys know it's
Christmas and I came across Santa Claus
yeah Santa how you been not too bad
thank you and I hope that all's well
with you how you doing my name is Ali
right what's your name nice to meet you
Alie my name is Ed Ed Ed yeah nice to
meet you Ed head uh-huh you're looking
solid well hopefully you don't mind me
asking how old are you well well you can
ask but you won't get an answer 55 well
maximum that's a good guess
maximum okay so what are you doing today
uh just mooching around you know I often
come here here the Speaker's Corner uh
to hear what people are saying and so on
and to meet people to get interaction
know what's going on in the world around
you good okay interesting so you're in
this outfit yeah is it just Christmas
season I it has to be obiously yeah yeah
it's it's just a bit of fun do you get
like kids taking pictures with you oh
yeah I mean not just kids but you may
have seen around here people that is
that your purpose today just to come and
maybe take pictures of the kids and just
yeah yeah I mean it's a it's a joyous
thing really you know it creates um bit
of fun for everybody you know so Santa I
mean the word on the street is is Santa
Claus an atheist is he a does he believe
in God what's what tell us what's your
belief well I certainly would think that
Santa CL any any Santa CL would believe
in God I think it's Bas as you you may
know on St Nicholas yes I think he was
from Turkey if I'm not mistak believe so
yeah I'm from Turkey oh right there you
are maybe Santa Claus is my great great
Grandad well who knows yeah well so I
think that's what it originates from and
I guess he must have been a guy who was
yeah yeah giving out presence of
children and things like that he must
have um you know exactly but you as the
other Santa CLA yeah what's your belief
do you believe in god oh absolutely yeah
okay are you are you a Christian um
well I I I'm loathed to um label myself
if you know what I mean okay um but
certainly I believe in God there's no
question about that okay um there are
these various stories and you I'm sure
you'll not be unfamiliar here you've got
people like Christians Muslims and a few
Jews as well and then all say I'm right
no no you're right and it goes on for
you know every week okay so you've got
to you you know it's hard to know which
stories are true which stories are not
true okay so let me tell you as a Muslim
our perspective sure and then we can
decide what is your belief system yeah
for example you believe in God yeah when
did you start believing in God has it
been always since you're a child is it
something you came to know have you ever
been an Atheist no I've always um had
the belief that there is a God simply
because it would it would be irrational
not to because everything that we see
around us is created uh in in in
intricate design and as we will all know
that if we uh if we take some sand or
whatever throw it on the floor it will
scatter into nothing maybe if we get
that same sand and we can mold it into a
shape of an animal and we can present
something but we had to have intelligent
thought to make that happen the sand
wouldn't form itself into like a rabbit
of its own
accord Ed you're a very intelligent man
it's very simple it's very intelligent
tell the truth many people yes sister
you speaking the truth and you've got
intelligence and it's simple I've spoken
to here to atheists who will come and
tell me that the Universe came from
nothing or it was a chance and to me
it's Preposterous actually to me it's an
intelligent and for you to come and just
say simply what you said is as Muslims
we % agree with that so now do you
believe God is a man do you believe he's
in the creation what's your thought Pro
proess of God what do you think God is
do you believe he can be a man well I
would be inclined to think number one
why would he be a man a man is part of
reproduction thank you yeah you see my
point so and also I would reason that if
God were to be a man yeah he is lacking
something because I'm lacking something
I'm a man but I don't have the
attributes of a woman so a woman has
qualities that I don't have exactly
surely God would have all qualities God
would have lack for no quality so I
don't think he would again like labeling
I don't think God would label himself
this or that I mean I think
probably
people get the uh idea that God is a man
because because they think that well you
know the masculine side of the world is
it dominates and gets things done and
think well that that must be what God is
you know but okay look you're getting
more intelligent as you're speaking I
have to ad I admire that you know why
because you speaking from reason and
rationality and logic and as Muslims we
believe that every person is born a
Muslim do you know why we say that
because of the stuff you just uttered
why because nobody had to come and tell
you that God is a not a man like I don't
need to come here and tell you by the
way Ed God is not a man you be like du
of course I know that or by the way Ed
there is no God you be like of course or
if I said there is God you're going to
say of course there is God what you're
doing is we call the in Islam so what we
call that is called the F what the fitra
means is you are innately programmed to
acknowledge God exist to acknowledge he
is one to acknowledge he is not the
creation but rather the Creator M the
stuff you just said to me is things a
Muslim says Ed are you a secret Muslim
tell me tell me tell me who knows so Ed
Jokes Aside you are uttering the words a
Muslim would say sure God there is God
that exists good you're not an atheist
anymore God is not a man he is unlike us
this is the definition that we give to
God Almighty sure like I'll recite a
verse in the Quran for you have you
heard the Quran before yeah okay I'll
recite it for you yeah so Allah says in
the
Quran say he God is
one
self-sufficient he does not beget nor is
he begotten and there is nothing like
him yes would you not agree with that I
wouldn't disagree with that he's also
agreeing with the Quran we're getting
there guys he's going to be become a
Muslim today I'm joking now the point is
this though yes our perception of God is
that we believe God has attributes we
believe God is the all knowing he's the
most powerful he's the all wise he has a
will that he will the universe and us to
come be now what God Almighty wants as
Muslims from us is what that you have a
relationship with him that you have a
connection with him because we in this
world will be lost so is there anything
about Islam that you don't know because
you already believe in the fundament
like the fundamental which is who God is
would you accept that God has to be all
knowing yeah all powerful absolutely all
wise yeah good good so there's certain
things that you believe in now is there
anything you don't know about Islam that
you had a question mark about well um
like I say there are so
many things in stories and people put
one perspective and other side put oh
that's wrong other perspective it's very
hard
um to really yeah I mean you will be app
you will appreciate the questions yes uh
they will say that um you know Jesus is
and I know that you you regard Jesus as
a prophet he's a prophet Mighty Prophet
but Christians say that Jesus is
actually the Son of God exactly or God
or yeah well effectively sort of you
know exactly God coming down as in
exactly but you as a person who's not a
Christian or a Muslim logically does
that make sense logically from from from
from from one perspective you could
argue that it doesn't make sense from
another perspective you can argue that
it does make sense if you are prepared
to accept these steps that you'll be
presenting but that requires Faith yes
now putting Faith aside and using logic
and rationality you said God cannot be a
man why because you used your
rationality you didn't use Faith well I
I can't say that God can't be a man but
logically it
wouldn't I'm sure God could be whatever
God wants to be okay so if God wants to
be a man I can't say you know okay good
what we say is God in his Essence and
nature for example can God
lie well
um attri the only way I can answer that
is um surely God can do what God what
whatever wants to do okay we say God
does whatever befits his majesty for
example can we say God con cease to
exist can God die well I suppose only by
by God's Own will could that happen I
don't know okay so we say he can't die
because if he dies then that will be
against his nature because he's the ever
living so what we see is God cannot lie
because he's lying is a something that
is not uh righteous it's not it's not
it's not something attribute of God
that's why we say God will never be a
man and cannot be a man this doesn't
limit God it actually shows his majesty
and who he is now have you read the
Quran
before no more really than
little touches here and there in the in
I gave him one
yes IOU that's good here and there but
but that would apply the same with the
Bible I haven't read the Bible little
touches here and there but with the
Bible um more I hear things so I'll hear
and and what have done throughout
growing up as a child you know you'll
hear stories and so on or sayings you
know um I me I got a good thing from the
from the Bible I can say you know I can
tell you you probably aware it in the
fact that um uh I think that
um uh Jesus I think said that you know
on the last day or whatever God will
turn to you and say uh you know you did
these bad things you did this and you
did
that and you you know you you did these
things today yeah and people will say no
God I didn't do these things to you and
God will say to you whenever you did
these things to sorry whenever you think
do these things to anyone you did it to
me oh yeah if you visit a sick person
God talking about the Hadith of the
Prophet Muhammad he be upon him he said
that um when I was not well you didn't
visit me and he said oh God you are the
he so you will never be unwell so he's
talking about a person who my servant
was ill and yes I've course very
important now I don't want to hold you
that much I want to end on this I've got
the Quran on my phone sure can you maybe
just do this like on a random chapter
and a random verse and may let's see if
there's a message in the Quran for you
so I'm going to go
to that inshah give me a second sorry
there we go so I want you to just pick a
random chapter just scroll and pick a
random
verse upward y sorry sorry just just
just like that just yeah sorry yeah yep
and okay and then pick a verse that one
any random any random okay let's see
what verse that is yeah okay so this is
Surah T
yeah okay Allah says in the Quran by the
Mount of T and by the book
written on the unrolled scroll and by
the populated
house and by the roof raised high and by
the Sea flared up with fire the
punishment of your lord is sure to fall
there is nothing to push it back the day
when the sky will tremble and and a
horrible trembling and the mountains
will move about a terrible movement so
wo to those day who reject the true
Faith which is Islam who are indulged in
vain talk playing with truth the day
they will be pursued be pushed to the
fire forcefully and it will be said to
them this is the fire you used to deny
is it there is it then magic or do you
not see enter it now whether you endure
it patiently or impatiently it is all
the same for you you are merely rewarded
for all what you used to do of course
the God-fearing will be in Gardens of
bliss enjoying what their lord would
have given to them and their lord would
have served them with the uh with and
and their Lord will have saved them from
the punishment of hell yeah it will be
said to them eat drink pleasantly
because of what you used to do now this
is talking about the people of Hellfire
and the people of paradise we want to
enter Paradise we want you to enter
Paradise as well and we say that that
could only happen with our relationship
with God Almighty so can you maybe when
you go home today
why don't you call out to God I did this
about 13 years ago I came I came to
Islam 10 years ago 13 years ago I was
embarking on my journey of finding the
true Faith right you you you were
brought up in Islam No oh you weren I
was not my dad is like an atheist I so
yeah so to me I prayed to God and said
God whatever is the truth guide me to it
I found Islam not only does the Quran
preserve hasn't been changed there are
many miracles in it historical Miracles
linguistic miracles the prophecies so I
would just ask you pray to God and ask
him and say God I believe you're there
please guide me to the truth because in
the Quran is talking about the people of
the fire who denied the Hellfire you
must accept that if God exists there
must be a reason he put us here on
because there has to be a purpose why
would God just put us here and leave us
on our own he must communicate with us
he wants good for us so therefore I want
to inshallah see you in Paradise so I
would say when you get home do a prayer
and say my God if you are there please
guide me and you've already been given a
Quran and that's it if you have any
other questions for me anything else
that's very good advice you've just
given me there I apprciate I will take
that take that please thank you you're a
sincere Maness man and I ask God
Almighty to guide you and myself it was
a pleasure you're a lovely person and
gentleman Santa Claus it's been a
pleasure and Merry Christmas to
everybody thank you very much thank you
take care thank thank you very much take
care I mean that's it guys uh it was
very interesting speaking to Santa Claus
I've been looking for him for the past
15 years I finally found him you know uh
but anyways brother sisters may Allah
subhana guide him um to Islam he seems
like a very nice person and Allah
subhana wa tala will guide those who
have good heart inshah till next time
from speak
Corum